c'est la première fois que david parle
david c'est un garçon vous savez qui est
marié c'est le fils aîné de johnny
hallyday c'est un taiseux ce qu'on
appelle un taiseux et un vrai artiste il
fait les chansons il parle très peu et
donne très peu d'interviews et pour la
première fois ça va sortir le 8 novembre
donc la semaine prochaine
il ya un livre de laurent lavige qui
sort et qui donne la parole à david
hallyday et laurent lavige est avec nous
bonjour laurent bonjour bonjour là
bonjour bonsoir laurent merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté d'être avec nous je sais
que vous n'êtes pas à paris aujourd'hui
sinon vous auriez en plateau juste une
question comment ça s'est passé ce livre
c'est david qui est du verre vous c'est
vous qui êtes allé vers lui
comment s'est passé ce cette rencontre
pour combourg déjà que j'ai mangé sorti
trois lurons qui ont obtenu le dernier
par une semaine après son décès ouais
mais je me suis retrouvé dans le
tourbillon médiatique à cet héritage que
lorsque j'étais sûre et à qui on avait
trouvé ça injuste et pas très tendre
voire même violence qui se pressait
autour de valider des de tous les cons
et moi comme je suis pour mettre des
choses c'est à dire mettre la musique au
centre de la relation c'est à dire entre
david et son père la relation musicale
injuste parce qu'en fait il est
quelqu'un de très discret c'est
quelqu'un de bien de très discret de 13
ans recule et déjà beaucoup de pudeur et
voilà je me suis dit je vais il écrit ce
livre j'ai réunis autour de jean temps
mais vous comprenez que ça va être une
bombe énorme le livre sort pas
complètement par hasard à cette date là
ça va être une bombe énorme c'est les
confessions de david j'ai vu quelques
passages notamment
on y apprend notamment que david après
l'album 100% une carte on a été écarté
un peu par laetitia qui a fait le ménage
autour de neige autour de johnny
hallyday pour imposer maxim nucci et
qu'il a été mise à l'écart notamment
déjà à l'époque par laeticia qui donc
déjà il ya il ya dix ans voulait
l'écarter de son père
par contre ce n'est pas tout à fait ce
qui est écrit en fait je t'aime moi mon
sentiment parce que j'ai dit que je dis
toi homs importante et la plus vendue de
l'histoire n'étant pas du dernier quart
temps pour d'autres raisons j'en connais
lesquels mais la donne 100% c'est là
tout au long de la carrière de johnny et
moi mon sentiment ce n'est pas david qui
le tour mon sentiment c'est
effectivement à la suite de la sortie de
cet album j'ai le sentiment on entre et
vie pour que on évite de soi toujours
près de la source de ces entités
travaillent en zone atlantis y ait
quelqu'un qui est formidable on se
trouve oui c'est pas moi je sais ce que
j'ai lu je peux pas forcément plus bête
qu'un autre c'est ce que j'ai compris
quand j'ai lu mais ça veut dire que
finalement c'est votre sentiment c'est
pas des choses que david vous a dit euh
en revanche on verrait que effectivement
dans l'interview de voici c'est mon
sentiment c'est le sentiment 2 par
rapport à betteraves
donc on s'y trompe et merci vous
recevoir par rapporter les incidents de
l'état présent de tout mais j'en profite
vraiment pour reconstituer un petit peu
la sortie de ce livre n'est pas un livre
sur les confessions de david sur son
père c'est le fruit de canton d'une
interview avec bédié pdci témoin de
comptable et de travailler à tort
surtout important j'ai très bien compris
le rang mais une question est ce que
david vous a donné son accord pour ce
livre parce que forcément nous quand on
lit on sait pas tous ces détails de
fabrication nous quand on lit et quand
je les lui mme j'ai lu des passages moi
j'ai le sentiment que c'est ce que david
vous avez dit est ce qui vous a donné
son accord pour ce livre avec vous je
n'ai moi je n'ai pas de doute depuis la
mort de son de son papa en revanche cet
été je les ai contactés pour le prévenir
que j'étais en train de dormir
qui sait parler de la relation hostile
entre le 8 et sans terre et que j'avais
utilisé depuis longtemps et ont cogné
mon qu'il est comme seront laquelle vous
appartenez à un accord
et vous n'a pas interdit non plus c'est
un peu d'activité qui peut trancher la
question pardon je sais qu'on fait pour
laurent mais c'est parce que mon essai
de la radio à l'antenne c'est un peu
compliqué une dernière question juste de
catherine rambert tu fais court aussi
catherine s'il te plaît et comme ça
après on vous laisse tranquille
bonjour laurent moi je suis quand même
une surprise vous dit à l'antenne que
vous avez compilé 20 ans d'entretiens
avec david et pourtant il ya une forme
de petites malhonnêteté part de l'émoi
dans votre la présentation du livre
parce qu'on croit vraiment qui vous a
parlé de son père de la ferme h
d'héritage et tout quand vous mettez tu
ne m'as pas laissé le temps qu'il soit
dit en passant le titre d'une des
chansons qui était dédié à son grand
père et c'est très bien que payet david
parce que moi je parle de la part de
geus et ses agents et sans que ses
conseils aux téléphones qui sont pas du
tout contents de la démarche
parce qu'en effet david n'a pas donné
son accord pour un livre qui joue sur
l'ambiguïté de l'actualité alors vous
avez compilé vincent lindon laisse
répondre et on vous laisse je pense que
vous devriez ont rempli les conseils de
répondre je pense que vous devriez à
nouveau reprendre et le soin de rappeler
les pe de tabriz et je pense que tu as
une vraie version
maintenant par rapport à 7 à ce titre
qu'il n'a pas le clip ont effectivement
c'est peut-être l'une des grandes
chansons l'un des grands types dans la
taille de 2 à 10 du cnir autre souci à
naître ce titre l'an suite on repense
forcément il y avait eu un problème de
la part de dd je pense que qu'il avait
plaisanté layton et de leur raid de deux
ans j'entends en tout cas merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions s'est pas vu en
tout par téléphone - le livre ça m'a dit
qu'il en ait vu les passages ça donne
envie de le lire
il sort lui
novembre voilà c'est une manne tu ne
m'as pas laissé le temps
le livre de laurent lavige et j'espère
que ce sera un succès en tout cas il
sort le 8 novembre merci beaucoup
d'avoir été vécue laurent merci encore